jetzt stellt die spd den kanzler und
olaf scholz muss ich gleich hier im
bundestag den sicher auch unbequemen
fragen unter anderem zur impfpflicht
stellen es gibt zeitbegrenzung kurze
fragen kurze antworten nur eine
nachfrage ist erlaubt es soll ein
spannender schlagabtausch werden vor ort
im bundestag beobachtet meine
kolleginnen aus dem hauptstadtstudio
andrea maurer die fragestunde die noch
nicht angefangen hat daher schalten wir
kurz zu ihr in den reichstag andrea was
ist denn heute von dieser fragestunde zu
erwarten
er vertritt er das parlamentarische
kreuzverhör dürfte heute für kanzler
scholz vor allem beim thema impfpflicht
unangenehm werden die union so hören wir
möchte druck machen sie will ihnen nicht
raus also kannst du scheiß nicht
rauslassen aus seinem zeitplan er hatte
die impfpflicht für märz angekündigt die
fraktionsübergreifende gruppenanträge
allerdings dem parlament überlassen
dieser zeitplan wackelt nun und die
union wirft dem kanzler führungsschwäche
vor die spd fraktion hat gestern
angekündigt sie will eckpunkte für einen
antrag in zwei wochen vorstellen auch
das dürfte als versuch zu verstehen sein
ein bisschen feuer aus der befragung
heute rauszunehmen aber natürlich wird
es auch um andere themen gehen natürlich
um die korona maßnahmen generell um das
thema taxonomie hören wir außenpolitik
mindeste und bildungsgerechtigkeit und
auch da durften wir wahrscheinlich von
der opposition die schärfsten fragen
hören herzlichen dank andrea bis hierher
wir sprechen sicherlich später nochmal
wir schauen jetzt mal ins plenum zu
beginn der heutigen sitzung wird es erst
eine kurze gedenkrede der bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas für den gerade
verstorbenen
eu-parlamentspräsidenten david soli
geben und wir hören jetzt mal kurz rein
die mitglieder des deutschen bundestages
den bürgerinnen und bürgern in unserem
land auch zuversicht geben dass die
politik auch im angesicht der großen
aktuellen herausforderungen
handlungsfähig ist und offen für
pragmatische lösungen
davids lars ohly wusste wie das geht die
traurige nachricht vom plötzlichen tod
des präsidenten des europäischen
parlaments
hat uns gestern erreicht
david sony war ein parlamentspräsident
der auf europäischer ebene genau das
konnte
kompromisse schließen das machbare
vorantreiben und das notwendige im blick
behalten die demokratie beweisen mit
david sony hat das europaparlament einen
leidenschaftlichen verfechter
europäischer humanitäre werte verloren
auch in schwierigen zeiten stand er
stets für seine überzeugung ein er
vertrat das parlament selbstbewusst
gegenüber dem rat und der kommission
der italienische sozialdemokrat verstand
es auch in seinem hohen amt sich klar zu
positionieren
und dennoch zwischen widerstreitenden
haltungen und interessen zu vermitteln
zugute kam ihm seine freundliche
verbindliche art
seine im journalismus geschulte
fähigkeit verständlich zu kommunizieren
in strittigen fragen wie der gemeinsame
asyl- und migrationspolitik macht es das
oli immer wieder deutlich dass er auf
der suche nach politischen lösungen das
schicksal einzelner nie verloren gehen
darf
davids hasso lieber ein überzeugter
europäer und ein großer menschenfreund
der deutsche bundestag wird ihm ein
ehrendes andenken bewahren
ich möchte sie bitten sich von ihren
plätzen zu erheben
ich danke ihnen dass sie sich von den
plätzen erhoben haben
ich komme nun zur tagesordnung zunächst
begrüße ich eine neue kollegin im plenum
klarer dünger hat für die ausgeschiedene
kollegin katja kipping die
mitgliedschaft des deutschen bundestages
erworben
herzlich willkommen
vor klarer dünger
und auf eine gute zusammenarbeit
so es geht jetzt einige minuten noch um
die tagesordnung wie wir gehört haben
gibt es auch noch eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte auf antrag der
afd da geht es um die arbeitsbedingungen
hier im plenum und zwar darum dass es
jetzt 2 g plus gilt wir haben ja viele
fdp abgeordnete die nicht geimpft sind
es gilt jetzt auch die regel dass man
also geimpft sein müssen wer nicht
gepustet ist braucht zusätzlich einen
test auch das verweigern einige
fdp-abgeordnete
bisher saßen die ungeimpften oben auf
der tribüne wie das heute gehandhabt
wird darüber soll nun diskutierten
diskutiert werden und wir hören rein
bevor es dann mit der eigentlichen
fragestunde losgeht für das plenum
bedeutet dies folgendes für den zutritt
zur parlamentssitzung soll fortan eine
2d plus regel gelten zudem soll die
bestehende masten pflicht dadurch
verschärft werden dass im plenarsaal
eine ffp zwei maske getragen werden muss
die zweite die 2g regel plus bedeutet
dass zutritt zum plenarsaal in der
unteren ebene ausschließlich diejenigen
personen erhalten die vollständig gegen
das saas koch 2 virus geimpft oder von
einer corona erkrankung genesen sind und
das ist das plus 2 das ist das plus der
zwei plus regel die darüber hinaus
negativ getestet oder gemustert sind
also eine auffrischungsimpfung erhalten
haben
dieser zweig plus status ist nach
maßgabe der allgemeinverfügung als
zutrittsberechtigung zur unteren ebenen
des plenarsaals uns zur west und
geordneten lobby
nachzuweisen diejenigen abgeordneten die
zwar weder geimpft noch gelesen aber
negativ getestet sind können unter
wahrung des abstands gebots auf den
tribünen platz nehmen und von dort aus
an der sitzung teilnehmen und zwar wie
gewohnt auch mit redebeiträgen
die eingangs erwähnte verschärfte masken
pflicht bezieht sich allein auf die
qualität der zu tragenden maske anstelle
von medizinischen masken zu denen auch
op masken gehören dürfen im plenarsaal
nunmehr nur noch fsb zwei masken
getragen werden diese ffb zwei masken
pflicht gilt wie zuvor auch am platz und
lässt aus nahm allein für die
amtierenden präsidentinnen und
präsidenten sowie für die rednerinnen
und redner am redepult und an den saal
mikrofon zu
bitte beachten sie auch die ausnahmen
und die befreiung aus medizinischen
gründen die die allgemeinverfügung in
bezug auf die 2g plus regeln und die
masken pflicht vorsieht
bevor wir jetzt zur abstimmung kommen
wird die fraktion der afd das wort zur
geschäftsordnung
ergreifen herr dr baumann
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
der bundeskanzler sagt bei der
bekämpfung des kroner virus darf es
keine roten linien geben ich sage ihnen
in einer freiheitlichen demokratie muss
rote linien geben
gerade hier im deutschen bundestag
werden sie heute einmal mehr
überschritten eine völlig neue
überzogene kroner verordnung greift tief
in das freie mandat der parlamentarier
ein selbst abgeordnete die sich hier
offiziell im bundestag direkt vor dieser
sitzung haben testen lassen und den
einwandfrei besteht bestätigt wurde dass
sie kein corona haben selbst diesen
abgeordneten wird jetzt der zutritt ins
plenum verweigert sie dürfen hier nicht
sitzen sie dürfen an diesem pult nicht
reden sie dürfen also ihre
verfassungsmäßige rechte nicht ausüben
das kann nicht sein das darf nicht sein
das kann nicht so bleiben meine damen
und herren
abgeordnete müssen jetzt über den klaren
negativ test hinaus zusätzlich noch
nachweise erbringen über doppelte
impfung oder genesung wozu das führende
deutsche verfassungsrechtler hat das
sofort alarmiert ich zitiere nur den
lehrstuhlinhaber für öffentliches recht
der universität oldenburg professor
boehme neßler warnte gestern mit blick
auf den bundestag sofort wörtlich
getesteten auf die tribüne zu verbannen
ist nicht erforderlich ist
unverhältnismäßig und ist damit
verfassungswidrig
deutlicher kann man es doch gar nicht
sagen meine damen und herren
sie schieben also nachweislich gesunde
auf die besuchertribüne ganz dort oben
wo sie von anderen abgeordneten nicht
gesehen werden sie halten also praktisch
saal verbot werden von der gemeinschaft
alle abgeordneten abgetrennt und so
schikaniert mit ihrer corona politik
spalten sie nicht nur die gesellschaft
spalten auch dieses parlament meine
damen und herren
wenn gleichzeitig dürfen andere
abgeordnete hier im plenum völlig
ungetestet sitzen nur wegen einer
sogenannten booster impfung dabei weiß
mittlerweile jeder dass selbst dreifach
geimpfte das virus übertragen können
niemand weiß wie viel hier vorne in
wirklichkeit infiziert sind
die einzig vernünftige regel wäre
deshalb alle zu testen das aber tun sie
nicht sie setzten sich damit den
erkenntnissen der wissenschaft entgegen
überdies wegen sie jetzt auch noch alle
abgeordneten trotz abstand halten statt
normale op masken jetzt die dicke ffp
zwei maske zu tragen immer und überall
den ganzen tag deren stunden langes
tragen
der schwerter atmen stört die
konzentration selbst professor wieder
präsident des robert koch-instituts
warnt diese masken seien für den alltag
nicht zu gebrauchen all diese
einschränkungen gefährden die arbeit der
abgeordneten spalten das parlament und
sie sind auch noch sinnlos wie sagt
bereits der zitierte staatsrechtler
wörtlich verfassungsmäßige rechte durch
sinnlose maßnahmen einzuschränken
erlaubt die verfassung auf gar keinen
fall halten sie sich daran meine damen
und herren
ja wie wir eben gesehen haben sind es
doch einige abgeordnete der afd die dort
oben auf der besuchertribüne platz
genommen haben es folgt jetzt eine
antwort der spd als nächste rednerin für
die spd fraktion katja mast
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren heute morgen
die neuesten
infektionszahlen
1430 die höchsten infektionszahlen seit
beginn der pandemie in berlin
9000 neue infektionen und deshalb bin
ich froh dass die
bundestagspräsidentin die initiative
ergriffen hat die allgemeinverfügung zu
verändern es ist absolut geboten und es
ist richtig dass wir die notwendigen
maßnahmen zum schutz von uns allen in
die wege leiten
grundsätzlich will ich aber auch sagen
dass die rechte der abgeordneten die
ausübung des freien mandats
überhaupt nicht in gefahr sind trotz der
schon geltenden geänderten
allgemeinverfügung fühlen wir hier diese
freie und offene debatte das ist ein
beleg dafür
und im gegenteil mit dieser
allgemeinverfügung
stärken wir die funktionsfähigkeit des
deutschen bundestags und
gewährleisten damit dass auch wichtige
entscheidungen in zukunft weiterhin hier
getroffen werden können
und weil es nicht nur um die
mandatsträgerinnen und mandatsträger
sondern auch die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter im deutschen bundestag in
den abgeordnetenbüros in der verwaltung
aber auch hier vor mir und hierbei den
saal dienerin und salina geht es geht
auch um den schutz der mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter hier im haus da haben
wir eine besondere verantwortung dafür
und was wegen hier was regeln wir wir
führen eine ffp zwei masken pflicht ein
die gilt in berlin ab samstag in allen
bereichen wir machen nichts anderes als
das was die menschen draußen im land
auch tun hier im deutschen bundestag und
2g plus in plenarsitzungen und
ausschusssitzungen und veranstaltungen
des bundestags bei jährigen
restaurantbesuche zweige plus und wir
tun hier als werde es im deutschen
bundestag nicht notwendig
es geht hier bringt als wir gegen stimmt
schutz der menschen im deutschen
bundestag genau so leben die menschen
müssen das auch tun wir erwarten es von
ihnen jeden tag und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir das so machen und auch
ihre ablehnung überbrücken sieht man ja
heute auch ob das sehr gut es gibt hier
vier fraktionen die sagen die alten
abstand auch im plenarsaal
sie finden dass es nicht notwendig auch
das zeigt ihre fünf entschuldigung
fraktion im deutschen bundestag
zeigen dass und sie wollen einfach den
menschen sand in die augen streuen und
sagen wir können diese pandemie nicht in
den griff bekommen durch unser fall nun
das gegenteil ist der fall des verheißen
von jedem einzelnen von jeder einzelnen
hat auswirkungen für die gesundheit in
diesem land und deshalb ist es richtig
was die parlamentspräsidentin in die
wege geleitet hat vielen dank für diese
änderung der allgemeinen
es wird jetzt gleich die abstimmung
geben ich glaube mal das wird relativ
schnell gehen da es keine geheime
abstimmung gibt und das ergebnis dürfte
wohl auch klar sein angesichts der
mehrheitsverhältnisse
ist der frei auch entschuldigungen dass
er vorher nicht bekannt ist wird doch
noch einen redner geben von der union
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist in der
tat die frage zu stellen worüber reden
wir eigentlich über eine verschärfte
masken pflicht und über 2g hier im
plenum des deutschen bundestages und ich
will das für unsere fraktion ganz klar
sagen wir halten das für eine richtige
und für eine notwendige entscheidung
denn es ist doch wirklich darauf
hinzuweisen in welchem umfeld bewegen
wir uns es sind nicht nur erstmals mehr
als 80.000 neue infektionen am heutigen
tag wir haben eine infektionsgeschehen
das etwa 130 prozent über dem des
vorjahreszeitraums liegt und wir haben
die situation dass wir hier in berlin
mitte eine inzidenz von neun
176,2 haben und deswegen muss man sich
doch auch fragen welches bild wir als
parlament in der öffentlichkeit abgeben
wir verlangen von den menschen
einschränkungen in form von
schutzmaßnahmen und mir als abgeordnete
wäre nicht bereit diese maßnahmen auch
für uns gelten zu lassen das ist nicht
akzeptabel dass es keine führung von
vorne und deswegen ist es wichtig was in
der allgemeinverfügung der präsidentin
drin steht
es sind nicht nur die menschen die man
ich will das auch an die kollegen sagen
von jedem schulkind in deutschland
erwarten wir dass es sich testen lässt
und sie und sie vergessen hier
krokodilstränen und schwadronieren über
die einschränkungen die damit verbunden
sind das ist nicht akzeptabel und
deswegen machen wir es so wie die frau
präsidentin vorgeschlagen hat und es
geht in der tat um zwei dinge es geht
zum einen darum dass wir einen beitrag
zum übergeordneten ziel dieser pandemie
bekämpfung leisten nämlich eine
überlastung des gesundheitswesens zu
verhindern und es geht auch darum dass
wir die funktionsfähigkeit des deutschen
bundestages aufrechterhalten weil wir
dafür sorgen müssen dass wir auch in
zukunft in der lage sind hier im
bundestag die notwendigen beschlüsse für
die zukunft unseres landes zu treffen
und deswegen verehrte frau präsidentin
bin ich ihnen und sind wir uns sind wir
ihnen als unions fraktion ausdrücklich
dankbar dafür dass sie hier das heft des
handelns in die hand genommen haben dass
sie die notwendigen maßnahmen getroffen
haben dass sie führung gezeigt haben
eine führung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wie wir sie uns auch von der
bundesregierung und den bundeskanzler
erwarten würden führung in schwieriger
zeit führung in einer der größten krisen
unseres landes diese führung erwarten
wir und deswegen verehrter herr scholz
nehmen sie sich ein beispiel an unserer
parlamentspräsidentin herzlichen dank
weitere wortmeldungen zur
geschäftsordnung liegen mir nicht vor
wir kommen damit nun zur abstimmung über
die eben erläuterte zweig plus regel
sowie über die verschärfte masken
pflicht im plenarsaal als teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung
wer stimmt dafür
dass in die fraktion die linke spd
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp cdu csu
fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
fdp fraktion gibt es enthaltungen
das sehe ich nicht damit sind die neuen
regeln als teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung beschlossen
wir kommen nun zu weiteren tagesordnung
für die heutige zehnte die morgige elfte
und die zwölfte sitzung am freitag haben
die fraktionen eine tagesordnung
vereinbart mit der ich den bundestag
einberufen habe nach § 21 absatz 3 der
geschäftsordnung ist für die genehmigung
der tagesordnung ein plenar- beschluss
erforderlich
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die noch zu beschließende tagesordnung
um die in der zusatzpunkt liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern von der
frist für den beginn der beratung soll
soweit erforderlich abgewichen werden
tagesordnungspunkt 4 wird abgesetzt
damit kommen wir zur feststellung der
tagesordnung der zehnten elfter und
zwölfter sitzung mit den genannten
änderungen wer ist für diese
tagesordnung
so also noch geht es hier um die
tagesordnung die abstimmung war wie zu
erwarten eindeutig anhand dieser
mehrheitsverhältnisse im bundestag ist
gelten jetzt die 2g plus regeln im
plenum das ist klar es wird gleich
losgehen mit der fragestunde
das gibt jetzt noch eine kurze
abstimmung und dann geht es gleich los
wir bleiben jetzt im plenum
vielen dank
damit rufe ich dann die tagesordnung den
tagesordnungspunkt eins auf die
befragung der bundesregierung die
bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
heute der bundeskanzler olaf scholz zur
verfügung steht herr bundeskanzler sie
haben das wort für ihre einleitenden
ausführungen
[Applaus]
präsidentin meine damen und herren die
bundesregierung hat sich heute erneut
mit dem thema beschäftigt das uns eben
auch schon bewegt hat nämlich die frage
der korona pandemie entschuldigung herr
kanzler jetzt unterbrechen ist sie weil
sie alle liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wissen dass das eine politische aktion
ist die wir hier in diesem hause nicht
dulden und insofern bitte ich sie jetzt
sofort das runter zu nehmen sonst muss
ich sie des saales verweisen und ich
behalte mir auch vor ein entsprechendes
ordnungsgeld für die ganze fraktion im
zweifel zu verhängen
jetzt ziemlich zügig übrigens auch da
oben weil sonst
und zwar alle sonst werden sie wirklich
des saales verwiesen
ja das meine ich ernst
alles gut alles gut wenn ich erwarte
auch dass sie jetzt nicht zwischendurch
immer wieder hoch gehalten wir das sage
ich auch ganz deutlich dann ist werden
sie wie gesagt einzelnen von sitzungs
betrieb heute ausgeschlossen so sind die
regeln
und jetzt herr bundeskanzler bitte ich
sie einfach noch mal an zu setzen und so
dass wir auch in die befragung des
bundeskanzlers gehen können frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren
kroner ich habe es schon gesagt ist das
thema das uns in diesen tagen alle
umtreibt die bundesregierung hat sich
heute erneut damit beschäftigt und
deshalb die kinder schutz verordnung auf
den weg gebracht das ist allerdings eine
teil entscheidung im rahmen vieler
vieler weiteren entscheidungen die wir
in der letzten zeit getroffen haben und
die vorbereitet worden sind hier in
diesem haus aber auch vorbereitet worden
sind in gemeinsamen zusammen in
zusammenkünften der länder und der
bundesregierung im november im dezember
und jetzt auch noch anfang januar wir
haben dabei entscheidungen vorbereitet
die dazu geführt haben dass deutschland
mit großer klarheit den weg durch die
pandemie weitergeht dazu gehören sehr
weitreichende kontakt beschränkung
weitreichender als in fast allen anderen
ländern der europäischen union
das gilt insbesondere wenn man sie in
der zusammenschau betrachtet wir haben
kontakt beschränkung im privaten bereich
nicht mehr als zehn personen und dort wo
die beteiligten nicht geschützt sind ist
es so dass nur zwei weitere hinzukommen
können wir haben kontakt beschränkung im
bereich
von zusammenkünften mit 2g und 2g plus
wir haben jetzt neu beschlossen dass das
auch gelten soll für den besuch von
restaurants als zweig plus wir haben
kontakt beschränkungen die die größe von
veranstaltungen betrifft das sind sehr
weitreichende maßnahmen sie haben aber
auch ihren gewünschten effekt denn das
infektionsgeschehen dass mit der neuen
omikron -variante verbundenes ist in
deutschland in ganz anderer weise als
anderswo bisher verzeichnet worden und
das ist auch zurückzuführen auf die
klaren weitreichenden maßnahmen die wir
fest nicht haben
darüber hinaus haben wir in deutschland
auch entschieden dass wir neben dem
impfen auch das boostern vorantreiben
auch in einem umfang und einem ausmaß
wie es in anderen ländern der
europäischen union nicht gleichermaßen
geschieht wir haben es geschafft bis
weihnachten 30 millionen solcher booster
impfung zustande zu bringen das war
unser gemeinsames ziel und wir arbeiten
jetzt daran
wir arbeiten jetzt daran dass es uns
gelingt weiter solche impfungen
musterung zu organisieren wenn es uns
gelingt wieder auf das niveau vor
weihnachten zu kommen das ist mein
ehrgeiz wenn die ferien jetzt überall in
deutschland zu ende sind über eine
million impfungen pro tag zustande zu
bringen in den vielen impfzentren und
impfmöglichkeiten in den arztpraxen dann
werden wir es auch schaffen dass das
auch einen weiteren eigenen beitrag zur
bekämpfung der pandemie leistet trotzdem
ist eins klar und das wissen wir sehr
genau
wir werden das infektionsgeschehen auch
sehen dass wir in anderen ländern haben
mit mehr infektionen wegen der omicron
variante ist heute schon erwähnt worden
wir haben jetzt etwa 80.000 infektionen
zuletzt verzeichnet und deshalb müssen
wir davon ausgehen dass höhere zahlen
wie wir sie anderswo sehen auch
hierzulande zu verzeichnen sein werden
ein grund genau diesen weg weiter zu
beschreiten und ein grund das will ich
an dieser stelle auch sagen warum ich
mich dafür einsetzen
unterstützt von vielen anderen wie ich
das gesehen habe im politischen raum
aber auch unterstützt von den
regierungschefin und regierungschefs der
länder
dass wir in deutschland eine impfpflicht
einführen ich bin sehr dankbar dass
diese debatte im deutschen bundestag nun
wo er wieder zusammentritt auch beginnt
und ich hoffe dass es an die zügige gute
beratung geben wird mit einer
entsprechenden ergebnis ich jedenfalls
halte sich für notwendig und werde mich
aktiv dafür einsetzen
wir entscheiden mit allem was wir
entscheiden nicht nur über uns und nicht
nur für uns allein denn die tatsache
dass in deutschland nicht so viele
geimpft sind wie wir am anfang der
impfkampagne gehofft haben als wir noch
gerungen haben darum dass möglichst
viele eine impfung überhaupt bekommen
können die tatsache dass wir nicht hoch
genug gekommen sind hat auch
konsequenzen
konsequenzen die mit den maßnahmen
zusammenhängen über die ich eben
beschrieben habe aber auch konsequenzen
die zum beispiel bedeuten dass wir
mittel bereitgestellt haben dafür dass
krankenhäuser operationen verschieben
können damit genügend betten für corona
infizierte zur verfügung stehen und
deshalb gibt es nicht die entscheidung
wo jemand sagt nicht betrifft das ja
nicht ich entscheide für mich impfen
mich nicht und das hat keine
konsequenzen für andere
doch für unser ganzes land für die
eigenen freunde für die nachbarn hat die
tatsache dass man jemanden anstecken
könnte eine konsequenz zum beispiel die
vielen mittel die wir aufwenden für die
krankenhäuser damit sie platz haben für
die infizierten zb das andere erdulden
müssen dass ihre operation später
stattfinden weil wir platz gemacht haben
für krone infizierte es gibt keine
entscheidung die man nur für sich
alleine trifft und deshalb ist die
impfpflicht auch richtig
heute
finden erstmals wieder seit langer zeit
gespräche im nato-russland-rat statt
gestern haben gespräche stattgefunden
zwischen den usa und russland es wird
gespräche geben im rahmen der osze und
wir sorgen aktiv dafür dass es wieder
möglichkeiten gibt das gesprächsformat
das normandie format zu beleben zwischen
den ländern die das auf den weg gebracht
haben um die krise in der ukraine zu
überwinden das ist eine ernste bedrohung
der sicherheit in europa der
truppenaufmarsch entlang der
ukrainischen grenze muss und sorge
machen und er macht mir persönlich auch
sehr sehr große sorgen es ist etwas
passiert
mit der annexion der krim nämlich dass
eine eroberte sicherheit eine die wir
politisch erobert haben miteinander in
europa das sicherheit nur gemeinsam
erreicht werden kann verloren gegangen
ist denn eine grundkonstante gehörte
immer dazu die gemeinsame erklärung dass
grenzen in europa nicht mehr verschoben
werden dass die territoriale integrität
der staaten ungefährdet bleibt und wir
müssen durch zu dieser situation wieder
zurückkehren das werden wir tun
eingebettet in die europäische union und
den die nato zusammen mit unseren
amerikanischen verbündeten werden wir
hier klar dafür sorgen dass diese dialog
formate alle wieder genutzt werden dafür
dass wir den notwendigen fortschritt für
sicherheit in europa erreichen
letzte bemerkung diese debatte in dieser
woche die wir sehen über die vielen
vorhaben die die neue regierung hat den
plan den sie hat dafür dass dieses ein
erfolgreiches jahrzehnt wird indem wir
die zukunftsaufgaben unseres landes
anpacken ist eine gute debatte ich freue
mich über all die diskussionen die wir
darüber führen denn das ist ja nicht nur
eine angelegenheit der regierung der
ministerin und minister die hier ihre
und unsere gemeinsame pläne für unsere
zukunft und für dieses jahrzehnt
vorstellen das ist eine angelegenheit
des ganzen hauses und unserer ganzen
republik und deshalb ist es eine gute
woche für ein signal des aufbruchs
schönen dunk
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler ich habe
bereits eine lange liste von
fragestellerin und fragestellern genannt
bekommen und wir beginnen mit
thorsten frei für die cdu/csu-fraktion
dass kanzler sie haben jetzt in ihren
ausführungen noch einmal erwähnt dass
die impfpflicht aus ihrer sicht ein
wichtiger bestandteil auf dem weg aus
der pandemie ist sie haben das auch
begründet diese meinung kann man teilen
oder auch nicht aber jedenfalls ist es
doch so dass wenn der bundeskanzler in
der größten krise unserer zeit sagt das
ist der weg aus der krise
dann muss der bundeskanzler und seine
regierung doch einen vorschlag einen
gesetzgebungsvorschlag dafür
unterbreiten wie man das ethisch richtig
und verfassungsrechtlich korrekt machen
kann und
wenn sie nicht die kraft dazu haben
einen solchen
gesetzgebungsvorschlag hier in den
deutschen bundestag einzubringen wo wir
ihn selbstverständlich diskutieren und
entscheiden und abgeordnete auch so
entscheiden wie sie es für richtig
halten dann müssen sie doch wenigstens
die fragen die aus diesem parlament
gestellt werden um eine solche frage
beurteilen zu können beantworten das
haben sie beispielsweise für unsere
fraktion nicht gemacht wir haben ihnen
vor weihnachten zahlreiche fragen
gestellt die für uns essenziell sind um
dieses thema zu bearbeiten und deswegen
möchte ich ihnen die frage stellen was
muss in unserem land passieren dass sie
bereit sind in einer so entscheidenden
frage die fragen der opposition und des
parlaments zu beantworten
schönen dank für ihre frage und für die
gelegenheit noch mal zu wiederholen was
im übrigen allseits bekannt ist an
position der bundesregierung und auch
des bundeskanzlers zu diesem thema ich
habe eben schon gesagt ich halte eine
impfpflicht für erforderlich ich habe
bereits als ich das im november das
erste mal gesagt habe und damit der
debatte in deutschland auch eine
richtung gegeben habe die vorher nicht
zu erkennen war dass ich von vornherein
richtig fand dass dies eine so
grundsätzliche angelegenheit ist dass es
besser ist die geschieht auf basis von
anträgen aus diesem haus ohne regierung
und opposition um fraktionszwängen
sondern ist eine entscheidung die die
abgeordneten ganz bewusst in dieser
frage anders treffen
selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ist es so
dass die bundesregierung alle hilfe
bereitstellt für diese anträge und
selbstverständlich ist es so dass der
abgeordnete olaf scholz auch eine ganz
klare meinung zu dem thema hat wie das
ausfallen soll und deshalb will ich ohne
der debatte die hier von ihnen allen
geführt wird vorzugreifen auch sehr klar
sagen was ich für richtig halte ich
glaube es sollte um alle erwachsenen
gehen ich glaube persönlich dass es auch
so ist dass es möglichst unbürokratisch
und schlank geschehen sollte dass man
keine großen strukturen etablieren muss
um das zu machen das geht auch bei
anderen dingen aber dass es notwendig
ist denn ich wiederhole was ich eben
gesagt habe mit der entscheidung sich
nicht impfen zu lassen trifft man nicht
nur eine entscheidung für sich sondern
für 80 millionen andere das merken wir
angesichts der korona
pandemie und der ist infektionsgeschehen
es ganz genau und deshalb wäre es gut
dass neben den vielen entschlossenen
entschiedenen maßnahmen die wir in
deutschland ergriffen haben diese
maßnahme als zusätzliche am horizont
fest geregelt ist damit alle bürgern und
bürger sich daran orientieren können
herr frey sie haben die möglichkeit eine
nachfrage zu stillen ja dann mache ich
davon gebrauch herr bundeskanzler sie
haben ja auch der bisherigen
bundesregierung angehört und wir haben
im dezember hier im deutschen bundestag
eine
berufsbezogene impfpflicht für komik 19
beschlossen können sie mir mal erklären
wo jetzt der unterschied liegt zwischen
der einbringung eines gesetzesvorschlags
der bundesregierung damals und einer
gewissensentscheidung heute
erstens
als jemand der diesem parlament schon
mehrere legislaturperioden angehört hat
und auch eine ganz tolle aufgabe in
diesem rahmen hatte einmal als erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
einer dieser fraktion will ich
ausdrücklich sagen mir ist wichtig dass
jede einzelne entscheidung eine spd
abgeordnete für sich selber entscheidet
ob er dem common folgen will dass man
dem mehrheitsvotum seiner fraktion
feucht oder ob man das in diesem fall
anders sehen will man muss es sich immer
nur habe ich den abgeordneten die anders
abstimmen wollten als die fraktion
erläutert genau überlegen denn auch da
trifft man nicht nur eine entscheidung
für sich sondern das muss man allen
anderen jahr erläutern es gibt aber
fragen wo wir uns darüber verständigt
haben auch in diesem parlament dass sie
so von so grundlegender bedeutung sind
dass es der sache dient wenn man einen
anderen weg geht also kein vorschlag der
regierung macht sondern vorschläge aus
dem haushalt über die dann abgestimmt
wird und dies ist einer dieser fälle die
ja gar nicht so selten sind und die aber
alle wenn wir diesen weg gegangen sind
immer zur befriedung der politischen
diskussion beigetragen habe und deshalb
ist mein beitrag dazu erstens ganz von
vorne weg gesagt zu haben ich bin dafür
als noch die meisten nicht dafür waren
zweitens den weg zu öffnen für diese
offene debatte und was ihre konkrete
frage betrifft was ist der unterschied
eine berufsbezogene impfpflicht ist von
ganz anderer dimension als eine die alle
bürger bürger dieses landes zumindest
alle erwachsenen sofort trifft und man
merkt ja auch an der aufgeregten debatte
worum es geht es geht etwas wo niemand
sagt dass beobachte ich im fernsehen da
habe ich auch eine meinung zu sondern
wenn wir eine impfpflicht festsetzen
betrifft das jeden einzelnen bürgern und
bürger jede bürgerin jeden bürger geht
es um unsere körper die wir alle haben
und deshalb ist es genau ein solcher
fall wo man diesen weg gehen soll es ist
der richtige es ist der richtige weg für
demokratische leadership
vielen dank normalerweise ist es ja so
dass man auch nachfragen jetzt aus
anderen fraktionen stellt ich will im
moment ich will das ganz offen sagen
davon absehen weil ich sehr viele
anmeldungen sowieso schon habe und ich
glaube es wird auch dadurch sehr
lebendig so dass möglichst viele
fragestellerin und fragesteller auch
dran kommen und ich möchte auch alle
auch den herrn bundeskanzler nummer
bitten dieser rote balken der berühmte
ist dafür da dass wir die redezeiten
dann auch sowohl der fragestellerin und
fragesteller aber auch von ihnen
einhalten nach möglichkeit damit eben
möglichst viele abgeordnete auch zu wort
kommen können die nächste frage stellt
für die spd fraktion bernd westphal
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler
mit beginn des jahres hat deutschland
die g7 präsidentschaft übernommen mich
interessiert welche schwerpunkte sie
aufgrund der bundesregierung formuliert
haben und vor allen dingen welche
schwerpunkte sie einbringen wollen in
bezug auf die transformation der
wirtschaft für die g7 staaten
schönen dank
die frage in der tat die g7
präsidentschaft ist in dieser zeit mit
einer ganz großen herausforderungen
verbunden
wir haben uns eine sehr klare agenda
vorgenommen die wir verfolgen worden im
gespräch mit den anderen demokratischen
industriestaaten mit denen wir uns dort
versammeln denn das ist ja das was uns
auszeichnet als zusammenkunft es geht
einmal dass wir die groß darum es gibt
vor allem darum dass wir die große
gesellschaftliche veränderung zustande
bringen die mit dem bekämpfen des
klimawandels verbunden ist und deshalb
werden wir all die industriellen
prozesse und die entscheidung die damit
verbunden sind zum großen thema dieser
debatte machen dazu gehört auch die
diskussion über einen klima klub wie ich
das genannt habe und wie wir das nennen
wollen mit dem wir erreichen wollen dass
diejenigen die miteinander kooperieren
wollen das auch tun würden wir werden
ländern ganz unterschiedliche maßnahmen
ergreifen um den klimawandel zu
bekämpfen sie werden alle auch
herausforderung mit sich bringen für die
industrie man muss sich dann verabreden
dass man einander nicht bekämpft sondern
in die gleiche richtung marschiert es
gibt weitere große frage punkte die ich
aber hier nur skizzieren will wegen der
kurzen zeit für die antwort also es geht
um die frage wie wir corona bekämpfen
können weiter als große
gemeinschaftliche aufgabe in der welt
denn wir werden das nicht nur in einem
einzelnen land gehen es geht um
infrastruktur entwickeln und es geht
natürlich auch insgesamt um all die
fortschrittlichen dinge die wir in der
welt auf den weg bringen müssen also
viele viele themen
vielen dank herr westphal sie haben die
möglichkeit eine nachfrage zu stellen
dann frau präsidentin nämlich gerne wahr
gleichzeitig haben unsere französischen
freunde ab januar die eu
ratspräsidentschaft übernommen sehen sie
auch in dieser verbindung synergien und
vielleicht gemeinsam die dinge die man
in abstimmung mit den anderen
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
in gang bringen kann es ist sehr gut
dass frankreich jetzt gleichzeitig mit
uns diese präsidentschaft dann hat weil
wir dann eng kooperieren können und das
haben wir uns auch fest vorgenommen bei
den gesprächen die wir schon miteinander
haben konnten zum ende des letzten
jahres wir werden insbesondere das schon
angesprochene thema des klimawandels
sowohl in der eu wie auch weltweit
verabreden müssen europa planen zb
angrenzt ausgleichsmechanismus um seine
industrie zu schützen wenn hier in
europa weitgehende maßnahmen ergriffen
werden um den klimawandel aufzuhalten
und dann ist es natürlich richtig dass
man das einbindet in die von mir schon
skizzierte internationale kooperation
einen klima klub damit nicht an streit
um gewissermaßen
celle stattfindet sondern eine
gemeinsame anstrengung zur bekämpfung
des klimawandels
zum aufhalten des klimawandels
vorgenommen werden wird und die themen
die wir ansonsten haben sind natürlich
verbunden auch mit der pandemie wie
kriegen wir die wirtschaft der länder
weiter vorangebracht wir haben mit dem
europäischen wiederaufbau programm eine
grundlage gelegt und die wollen wir
jetzt auch für die zukunft so entwickeln
dass die länder auch nach der krise
weiter
vorankommen und wachsen kann
vielen dank als nächster fragesteller
für die fdp-fraktion timo grub alam
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler die
korona maßnahmen aber auch krone an sich
verschleiert er den blick vor dem
wirklichen problem das hat man ja gern
ausführungen zum anfang auch wirklich
wahrgenommen wir stehen in deutschland
vor massiven problemen herausforderungen
veränderungen die unsere bürger wirklich
umtreiben neben den
unverhältnismäßigen
freiheitsbeschränkungen treibt die
bürger natürlich auch streichen
steigende verbraucherpreise
explodierende energiekosten und eine
massive ansteigende inflation um der
sektor energie versorgung ist ein
prominentes beispiel die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage wird die erhöhung der co2
steuer abgabe aufgezehrt die politik
kann dafür sorgen den strom für die
breite masse der gesellschaft auch
wieder bezahlbar zu halten weitere
beispiele für eine entlastung der
normalen bürger liefern unsere
europäischen nachbarn zum beispiel polen
senkt die mehrwertsteuer auf kraftstoffe
aber auch für verbrauchs gegenstände es
hat meine frage mit welchen politischen
maßnahmen werden sie der inflation
entgegenwirken die ja wirklich
mittlerweile auch im eu-raum ausufernd
ist und wie sieht eigentlich ihre
exit-strategie aus der korona zeit aus
wanna bundeskanzler kann die wirtschaft
können die bürger in diesem land wieder
frei atmen
schönen dank für ihre frage will die
letzte zuerst beantworten über die wir
eben auch schon gesprochen haben ich
glaube dass genau die strategie die wir
hierzulande verfolgen die richtige ist
kontakt beschränkung festzusetzen
insbesondere für diejenigen die bisher
den weg nicht gefunden haben zu einer
impfung aber auch insgesamt dadurch
dafür zu sorgen dass das
infektionsgeschehen nicht so explodiert
wie es ohne die maßnahmen ergriffen
haben explodieren würde und gleichzeitig
alle aufrufen sich impfen zu lassen
diejenigen die schon im schutz haben
aufzurufen und eine dritte impfung sich
zu holen weil das dazu beiträgt dass wir
mit der pandemie besser umgehen können
und wir haben ja schon in den letzten
vier in den letzten jahren der pandemie
aber auch jetzt immer noch sehr
umfassende wirtschaftshilfen auf den weg
gebracht um arbeitsplätze und wirtschaft
zu retten von der kurzarbeit angefangen
fortgesetzt bis hin zu den möglichkeiten
die wir für jedes einzelne unternehmen
auf den weg gebracht haben was die frage
betrifft wie wir mit den energiepreisen
umgehen können wollen ganz klar da ist
ein globales problem die preise steigen
überall in der welt die werden teurer
wenn man sie auf den internationalen
märkten einkaufen will und deshalb ist
es notwendig dass man etwas macht eine
der maßnahmen die wir ergreifen wollen
haben sie schon skizziert aber ein
bisschen klein gemacht wir wollen
spätestens anfang nächsten jahres die
eeg-umlage abschaffen und das ist genau
das vorhaben das dazu beiträgt dass jede
familie um 300 euro entlastet wird das
aber gleichzeitig dazu beiträgt viele
mittelständische unternehmen auch eine
entlastung bekommen
der kubaner sie haben die möglichkeit
eine nachfrage zu stellen ja also mir
geht es nicht nur um die unternehmen da
geht es auch um die allgemeinen bürger
die jeden tag ihre stromrechnung
bezahlen müssen sie haben einen ausweg
schon angedeutet aber es gibt ja mehrere
auswege aus dieser auch finanziellen
krise was die energiepreise angeht da
muss man sich ja muss man europa
umschauen die kernenergie wurde ja auch
mitarbeiter von der eu als nachhaltig
eingestuft und rund um deutschland
werden aktuell neue kernkraftwerke
gebaut wie wollen sie nun in deutschland
gerade in diesem bereich in forschung
und entwicklung in diesen dingen wieder
an die weltspitze führen oder gibt es
hier wieder einen sonderweg in
deutschland die nutzung der kernenergie
ist nicht nachhaltig und das sehr klar
zu sagen und sie ist auch wirtschaftlich
nicht sinnvoll
es sind erhebliche investitionen die
notwendig sind um neuen kernkraftwerken
gewissermaßen dafür zu sorgen dass die
stromversorgung in den ländern
gewährleistet ist wir wissen dass die
auch nicht ständig laufen sie bericht
hören immer die berichte über
ausfallende kernkraftwerke gar nicht
wegen sicherheitsproblemen sondern weil
sie aus verschiedensten gründen nicht
liefern können und deshalb ist das ein
teurer weg bei dem viele dinge noch
ungeklärt sind zum beispiel die
entsorgungsfrage und unverändert die
sicherheitsfrage alle statistischen
berechnungen die einige leute am
vorhalten dass es ja nicht gefährlich
ist sind ja in dem augenblick vorbei wo
es dann doch einmal passiert bei einem
atomkraftwerk und man wohnt in der nähe
und die nähe ist dann ziemlich ein
großer radius das muss man dazu sagen
weil das eine solche gefahr erst hat
sich deutschland entschieden aus der
nutzung der atomkraft auszuschalten es
ist richtig auszusteigen das ist richtig
und wir und wir haben einen anderen weg
auf uns auf einen anderen weg gemacht
nämlich dass wir die erneuerbaren
energien nutzen wollen und dass wir sie
ausbauen und genau das machen wäre und
wir werden die planungsverfahren die
genehmigungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
dass wir es schaffen aus erneuerbaren
energien aus windkraft auf hoher see
windkraft an land aus solarenergie aus
biomasse die energieversorgung
deutschlands sicherzustellen das ist
eine die uns international unabhängig
macht die dem klima dient und die am
ende die billigste sein wird und unser
wirtschaft dann ein wettbewerbsvorteil
schafft wenn wir das geschafft haben und
das beginnt jetzt in diesem jahr mit
dieser region
vielen dank und ich erinnere noch mal an
den roten balken nächste frage für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen die
abgeordnete kathrin league
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler sie haben die klimakrise
und den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
ja gerade schon angesprochen
minister hauk hat gestern die aktuelle
klimabilanz vorgestellt und das ergebnis
war für mich dass wir dringend
ambitionierte maßnahmen umsetzen müssen
um die klimaziele einhalten zu können
deshalb wäre meine frage welchen
stellenwert hat der schnellere ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien in dieser
legislaturperiode für sie und die
regierung
vielen dank es ist ganz klar wir
brauchen mehr strom darüber habe ich
mich mit vielen in den letzten vier
jahren immer gestritten und nicht alle
überzeugen können außer kurz vor ende
und deshalb wiederhole ich noch einmal
wir werden schon im jahre 2030 mehr
strom brauchen als wir ihn heute
nutzen das wird eine größenordnung seien
nicht von 600 sondern von knapp 800
terawattstunden nach allen berechnungen
die man braucht vielleicht etwas weniger
aber in dieser größenordnung deshalb ist
unsere aufgabe so zu beschreiben wir
müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir als
ersatz ersatz schaffen für die
atomkraftwerke und die kohle kraftwerke
für die stromerzeugung und für den
zusätzlichen bedarf den wir und alles
das muss mit großen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien verbunden sein
darum hat die regierung sich auch
entschlossen dass jetzt sofort auf den
weg zu bringen und sich den schneid
nicht abkaufen zu lassen sondern das in
diesem jahr zu machen was notwendig ist
damit das tempo über die ganzen zehn
jahre und die nächsten 25 jahre bis 245
auch eingehalten werden kann ich bitte
das parlament uns zu helfen denn den
schneid den dürfe nicht nur wir uns
nicht abkaufen lassen sondern auch das
parlament sich nicht jetzt müssen es
machen
sie haben die möglichkeit für eine
nachfrage
vielen dank welche bedeutung hat denn
für sie die der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien in bezug auf den wirtschafts
und industriestandort deutschland
es ist ganz klar klimaneutrales
wirtschaften dass alle länder der welt
in den verschiedenen internationalen
konferenzen für sich als zielperspektive
formuliert haben unterschiedlich schnell
aber doch alles um die mitte dieses
jahrhunderts zu erledigen klimaneutrales
wirtschaften wird nur gelingen wenn wir
sehr viel mehr strom einsetzen können
als heute deshalb schon das wachstum in
der kurzen zeit bis zum ende dieses
jahrzehnts aber das wird sich bis zum
jahre 2045 wenn wir klimaneutral
wirtschaften wollen noch mal erheblich
ausweiten es werden die doppelte menge
strom als heute sein vielleicht die
dreifache menge denn wenn die
stahlindustrie die chemieindustrie die
zementindustrie der maschinenbau wenn
die alle die man neutral wirtschaften
wollen dann werden sie das zuallererst
nutzen indem sie für heutige prozesse
strom einsetzen der dann aus
erneuerbaren quellen stammen muss und
gleichzeitig brauchen wir sowohl für die
energieerzeugung wie auch für die
industriellen prozesse in einem ganz
anderen ausmaß als heute wasserstoff und
auch das werden wir entsprechend auf den
weg bringen müssen es geht also um
industriepolitik um den industriellen
wohlstand und die globale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres landes und
ich bin überzeugt der weg den wir
einschlagen wird die stärken
vielen dank die nächste frage stellt für
die fraktion die linke frau ferschl
ja vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler
sie haben in ihrer neujahrsansprache
gesagt und ich zitiere eine ordentliche
bezahlung ist auch eine frage des
respekts und deswegen wollen sie auch
den mindestlohn erhöhen uns freut dass
sie da unseren vorschlag aufgreifen wir
unterstützen das
allerdings ist ja damit nur von seinem
verdienst leben kann nicht nur die höhe
des stundenlohnes entscheidend sondern
auch das stunden volumen also der
arbeitsumfang das gilt für die soziale
absicherung und auch für die spätere
rente jetzt hat juri koalition
beziehungsweise im koalitionsvertrag ist
festgeschrieben dass sie eine ausweitung
der minijobs planen das ist genau die
beschäftigungsform vor dem er eben kein
ausreichendes einkommen hat von dem er
keinen anspruch auf arbeitslosengeld hat
und auch keinen anspruch auf eine
eigenständige rente und die frage was
hat denn das eigentlich diese ausweitung
mit dem respekt zu tun von dem sie immer
reden
schönen dank für ihre frage auch für die
gelegenheit nochmal darauf zu verweisen
dass das in der tat eines der ganz
großen reformvorhaben diese regierung
ist dafür zu sorgen dass der mindestlohn
für den ich mich sehr früh eingesetzt
habe dass er in deutschland eine
mehrheit findet auch als das keineswegs
bei allen auch in ihrer partei schon
eine mehrheitsmeinung war und außer
drücke ich habe ich mich dafür
eingesetzt dass er kommt und jetzt dass
er auch noch mal angehoben wird auf eine
höhe die dann für die regelmäßigen
anpassung eine bessere basis ist als das
heutige niveau und das ist der grund
warum das stattfinden wird es wird knapp
zehn millionen bürgern und bürger dieses
landes eine gehaltserhöhung mit sich
bringen und das ist genau der weg den
wir hier zu lande gehen müssen es geht
um viele bürgern dieses landes die nicht
genug verdienen das wird sich ändern
und was die frage betrifft der minijobs
die wollen wir nicht ausweiten das haben
sie falsch gesagt wir erhöhen die grenze
wo es möglich ist nach den regeln des
mini jobs die sozialversicherung sich
rechtliche abwicklung und die
steuerrechtliche abwicklung vorzunehmen
das ist nämlich das was sich mit einem
minijob verbindet und dort haben wir
eine klare regelung getroffen
die nämlich sich auch sehr an verbindet
mit der erhöhung des mindestlohns wenn
man das umrechnet dann sind das etwa 10
stunden die woche die bei 12 euro
mindestlohn rauskommt und das ist eine
grenze von der wir glauben dass man
sagen darunter kann man das vertreten
darüber soll es dann sein dass das
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung ist und damit die
beschäftigung noch attraktiver wird
haben wir die midi job grenze also wo
der arbeitnehmer nicht den vollen
beitrag zur sozialversicherung zahlen
muss aber den vollen schutz bekommt die
per werden wir noch einmal ausweiten das
sind also zwei maßnahmen die dazu
beitragen dass männer und frauen die
wenig geld verdienen ein besseres
einkommen haben und dann werden wir
dafür sorgen dass möglichst viele gute
sozialversicherungspflichtige jobs in
deutschland entstehen das ist das
wachstum um das wir uns bemühen
ja vielen dank und wie gesagt der rote
balken ist ein signal
die nächste frage
für die fdp fraktion als entschuldigung
für schuldig und tschuldigung kommando
zurück denn die sie dürfen noch eine
nachfrage stellt ja vielen dank herr
bundeskanzler sehen sie es mir wirklich
nach aber das ist augenwischerei in dem
moment wo man die verdienstgrenze beim
minijob dynamisiert weiten sie natürlich
die minijob regelung aus und kreieren
dadurch eine ausweitung dieser prekären
beschäftigungsformen und sie haben sie
haben letztendlich gesagt dass das oder
im koalitionsvertrag steht drin dass man
verhindern will dass reguläre
beschäftigung durch minijobs ersetzt
werden soll aber genau das ist doch
schon passiert ungefähr eine halbe
millionen sozialversicherungspflichtige
jobs sind in mini jobs umgewandelt
worden und ich frage sie nochmal wie
wollen sie das verhindern
wenn sie jetzt die minijob regelung
ausweiten
zunächst mal widersprechen dass die
beobachtung der letzten jahre betrifft
als der allgemeine gesetzliche
mindestlohn eingeführt wurde sind sehr
viele die bis dahin im rahmen des mini
jobs tätig waren in
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung über gewachsen
und
deshalb stimmt nicht was sie so sagen
man muss manchmal einfach eine statistik
angucken und kein flugblatt das ist dann
glaube ich die bessere form sich zu
informieren aber unabhängig von dieser
frage ist es so dass ich glaube dass der
wichtigste was wir tun müssen ist dafür
zu sorgen dass viele gut bezahlte jobs
entstehen und das ist gerade in der
jetzigen situation besonders erfolg
versprechend denn wir merken ja auch am
ende der korona pandemie wo wir uns
irgendwie allmählich hoffentlich
hinbewegen trotz der dramatischen
situation die wir jetzt noch haben dass
viele ihre jobs verlassen haben weil sie
bessere gefunden haben und deshalb ist
es eine große chance dass wir in
branchen in denen bisher wenig bezahlt
wurde jetzt bessere jobs bekommen auch
tarifvertraglich abgesicherte und auch
welche mit mehr arbeitszeit und genau
das ist unser programm
vielen dank nächster fragesteller für
die fdp fraktion bernd reuther
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler wie ich
möchte eine frage zum wirtschafts und
industriestandort deutschland
stellen die
sperrung der autobahn a45 im sauerland
in nordrhein westfalen aufgrund eines
maroden brückenbauwerks hat massive
auswirkungen negativer art auf den
verkehr in nordrhein westfalen aber auch
in unserem ganzen land auf dieser
wichtigen nord-süd-verbindung besonders
betroffen im negativen sinne sind
natürlich die menschen vor ort im
sauerland aber auch die vielen
mittelständischen
unternehmen und daher möchte ich sie
herr bundeskanzler fragen in welcher
pose priorisierung werden sie wird die
bundesregierung den abriss und den
neubau dieses brückenbauwerks angehen
damit der verkehr auf dieser wichtigen
autobahn wieder fließen kann
schönen dank auch für diese frage zu
einem ganz konkreten fall ich kann ihnen
versichern dass wir uns in der regierung
darüber schon sorgfältig unterhalten
haben der verkehrsminister wissing hat
mir darüber berichtet und auch gesagt
dass er wie er dort konkret vorgehen
will was den abriss betrifft und eine
möglichst beschleunigte neubauplanung
damit das auch alles gelingen kann ich
bin sicher und das gehört ja zu den
vorhaben die die bundesregierung hat
dass wir das alles nur schaffen werden
wenn wir die vielen gesetze die wir zur
planungs beschleunigung durchsetzen
wollen auch auf den weg bringen können
denn das wird dann für dieses konkrete
aber auch für viele andere vorhaben
helfen und außerdem kann ich ihnen sagen
dass minister wissing entschieden ist
dafür zu sorgen dass sämtliche
entsprechende ingenieurbauwerke der
bundesautobahn einmal so drauf
durchgesehen werden und überprüft werden
damit wir zumindest die lage richtig
verstehen und dann die richtigen
konsequenzen daraus ziehen können
wir nehmen uns an dieser stelle aus der
fragestunde aus und schalten noch einmal
kurz zu meiner kollegin andrea maurer
andrea wie ist denn dein eindruck vor
ort ist olaf scholz heute irgendwie
unter druck geraten es ging ja nicht nur
um die impfpflicht
ja also unter druck geraten kann man
nicht sagen das was wir hier im
parlament heute erleben ist relativ
handzahm und da wo es unangenehm für ihn
hätte werden können also zwischenrufe
der afg oder auch die fragen der union
zur impfpflicht da hat er sich
unbeeindruckt gezeigt auf den vorwurf
ist fehle jemand führung in der frage
der impfpflicht hat scholz von
demokratischem leadership gesprochen
also er habe sich persönlich
positioniert und die frage sozusagen
allerdings also die antrags frage dem
parlament überlassen tatsache aber ist
es hakt und wenn jemand einen so
deutlichen zeitplan vorgibt wie der
kanzler nämlich impfpflicht im märz dann
muss er sich daran messen lassen dazu
aber haben die abgeordneten ihn heute
relativ leicht also stand jetzt raus
kommen lassen aus dieser frage gab es
denn sonst irgendein thema bei dem er
unter druck geraten ist was für ihn
irgendwie brenzlig war
also in wahrheit nicht bisher sozusagen
über anfragen zur taxonomien zu den
energiepreisen scholz hat auf alles
sachlich geantwortet und man muss
wirklich sagen also parlamentarisches
kreuzverhör war das hier nicht es war
einfach eine fragestunde eine antwort
runde und man kann nicht sagen dass er
hier tatsächlich irgendwie unter druck
geraten ist ja herzlichen dank andrea
wer die debatte weiter verfolgen will
kann das auf phoenix machen hier im
programm geht es jetzt weiter mit der
sendung heute in deutschland ich bedanke
mich für ihr interesse wünschen noch
einen schönen tag und sage tschüss bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]